NICOLA MARZARI: OK.
Welcome, everyone,
lecture 12, second part
of molecular dynamics, also
after the spring break.
So I decided to spend two or
three slides in reminding you
what was going on
from last time.
And I've actually
been intrigued.
I'm starting with
Heraclitus because this
is a beautiful citation.
So this is, you know,
fifth century BC.
But there is the intuition
that a macroscopic property,
like the river, actually comes
from a microscopic property.
That is the water molecules.
Though he wouldn't know
what a water molecule
is, but comes from what the
water molecules are doing.
So Heraclitus was saying, you
cannot step twice in the same
river.
Because the molecular
conformation
is always different, but the
river is always the same.
Anyhow, reminder of what
we have seen last time--
first of all, of course,
the standard thing
is that we have looked at
Newton's equation of motion.
Really, molecular
dynamic simulations
involve the integration
of these couple
set of second-order
differential equation.
So if we have n
particles, there are
going to be n
trajectory defined by,
for each particle, how the
vector position evolves
with time.
And the force acting
on each particle
can be obtained
from the derivative
of the potential field.
And all the particles
interact with each other.
So this is still a
many-bodied problem,
although a much
easier one to solve
than the electronic problem.
And we sort of remind
you how we integrated
this equation of motion.
But sort of one of the
fundamental concepts that we
have seen is how
we can use actually
the integration of the molecular
dynamics equation of motion
to obtain thermodynamical
quantities.
And you see what I'm
writing here on the left
is really the Boltzmann
idea, the sort
of basic idea of
statistical mechanics.
That is, if you have a certain
variable that I'm generically
calling here A, what we
know is that the expectation
value for that
thermodynamical variable
is given by the integration
over all the phase
space, integration
over all the position,
integration over all the momenta
of the value of that variable A
for every position
and every momentum
weighed with the appropriate
probability distribution.
So this would be,
say, for what we
call a canonical distribution,
a distribution in which
each microstate, its single
position and momentum,
is weighed with the
exponential of the energy
with a coefficient
beta that is just 1
over the Boltzmann constant
times the temperature.
And this fundamental sort of
statistical mechanics approach
can actually be translated into
a molecular dynamics approach.
That is we can actually
obtain the same expectation
value for the operator A without
really doing these integrals.
These integrals are obviously
impossible to perform
explicitly as soon as
you have many particles
because the dimension of
your phase space explodes.
And we have seen it
over and over again
that, as the
dimension increases,
it becomes increasingly
difficult or computationally
impossible to perform
these integrals.
But what we can actually
do is evolve our system.
But, remember,
our system is just
a point in phase space, the
collection of all position
and momenta.
We evolve it with the molecular
dynamics equation of motion.
And in particular,
say for this example,
we need to evolve it in what
we call the canonical ensemble.
That is we need to evolve
under the condition
that the temperature of
the system is constant.
But in this trajectory,
in this evolution,
we can average for each
instant of this trajectory what
is the instantaneous value
of your observable A.
And the average
over the trajectory
gives us an expectation value.
And these two quantities
are equivalent.
They are obtained in
two different ways.
Here, as an average
over the trajectory,
that is much, much simpler
to do computationally.
And here is an average
of all phase space.
And there is a subtlety about
this equivalence that is called
the hypothesis of ergodicity.
That is, in order for this
equivalence to be valid,
we really need to think that
our system spans the phase
space with the appropriate
probability distribution
without being confined
in corner of phase space.
And I'll give you an
example later on of what
means being confined.
So in a way, we sort of
work under the hypothesis
that really this trajectory is
spanning an appropriate sample
of trajectories.
And so when you do a molecular
dynamic simulation-- again,
reminder of last class--
you really perform an ideal
computational experiment
in which you start
deciding what are
the position and the velocity
of all your particles.
And then this is sort of the
computationally important step.
You integrate the
equation of motion.
And this is the sort
of step in which
you need to pay particular care
and attention on the algorithm
you use to integrate
your equation of motion
and, also, on the accuracy
that is needed to integrate
this equation of motion.
And once you have put all
your particles in motion
and you are sort of integrating
them and evolving them
according to the
appropriate equations,
well, you just need to make
sure that you wait long enough.
That is that you
equilibrate your system,
so that you
basically lose memory
of your initial condition.
You see, your system
starts from a choice
that has been made
by you and by hand.
And in data, it's
never representative
of what could really be a
microscopic configuration
of your system.
You're putting molecules
certain position,
and you're giving
them velocities.
But that's just your assumption.
And so you need to lose memory
of this initial condition.
And that's accomplished
by evolving the system
long enough.
And how long is the time
needed to reach equilibrium
is something that
depends on your system,
depends on the
temperature at which you
are performing a simulation.
But it's something
that you can check
in the course of
your simulation.
And again, I'll
show you an example
on how you check for
appropriate equilibration.
And once you have
reached equilibrium,
well, then it becomes
straightforward to just
calculate the results
of your experiments.
That is calculate, say, what are
the thermodynamical averages.
And so you start
accumulating what are
your quantities of interest.
And again, sort of reminder of
last class, the initialization
step involves choosing
the initial position
and the initial velocities.
And we need position
and velocity
because really we are dealing
with second-order differential
equations.
It's more critical to
choose appropriately
the initial position
and more difficult.
If you are studying a
system that is crystalline,
obviously it's very simple.
You start just with sort of a
periodic arrangement of atoms.
But say if you are starting
something more complex,
like, say, liquid water,
it becomes more critical.
Because your liquid,
as a structure,
that is not immediately
evident to you
when you try to put
molecules around.
Anyhow, there are sort of
obvious things to avoid.
That is you want to avoid that
atoms overlap too closely.
Because if you put two
atoms too close together,
they will have an
initial repulsive
force that is very strong.
And they'll just zoom away
very quickly from each other.
It's much more critical to
equilibrate with respect
to position than with
respect to velocities.
Velocities, or if you want
the phrase space part,
the momentum part
of your phase space,
is much easier to integrate.
Basically, because in any
collision between atoms
or between molecules, the
velocity, if you want,
get reversed.
And so in the momentum, in the
velocity part of phase space,
your representative points
can really jump around.
Say, if you had an ideal
gas of hard spheres
that only collide when
they touch each other--
and in an elastic
collision, they
just reverse their velocity--
well, in that case, your
representative point
is really jumping
around discontinuously.
So in velocity space, you
really move around very easily.
And you span all
the phase space.
It's really in the position
part of the phase space
that you need to be careful
and where your system
can become entangled.
Once you have set up
your initial position
and your initial
velocity, you have
everything you need to integrate
your equation of motion.
And to integrate
equation of motion,
there are a variety
of algorithms.
And I have mentioned,
and you'll see again,
the standard or simple
Verlet algorithm.
That is actually a very robust
and very accurate algorithm.
So it's what you'll
see in the next slide,
but there are sort of different
varieties of Verlet algorithm.
Sometimes you see them called
leapfrog Verlet or velocity
Verlet depending on the
specific integration scheme.
And then there is another class
that I'll also mention briefly
just for reference
that are called
the Gear predictor-corrector
integration algorithm.
So this, more or less,
relies on all the zoology
of integration algorithm.
And obviously, one of
the important qualities
of your integration algorithm
is that it must be robust.
That is it shouldn't be
too sensitive on the choice
of discretization.
Remember, we have sort
of differential equation
that are basically perfect
analytical equation.
But in order to integrate
them on a computer,
we need to discretize them.
And again, sort of one of the
key features of your simulation
is figuring out what is
the discretization interval
or what we call the time step.
That is how much
time you can spend
before you calculate another
point in your trajectory.
And there are sort of
a lot of subtleties
that we won't go into on what
really makes a good integrator
for the equation of motion.
In particular, one of the
properties that we would want
is that it's time reversible.
And that's what the
simple Verlet is.
That is, if you invert
all your velocities,
your trajectory is recovered
in the opposite direction.
And not all algorithms
actually are time reversible.
And then there is something
a little bit more subtle.
That is a sort of
criterion of robustness
for an integrator
is that it preserves
the volume of your
representative system in phase
space, but we really want
to go into these details.
There are sort of, you
know, several classes
of molecular dynamic
simulations depending
on what is the thermodynamical
ensemble that you
want to represent.
That is, if you
straightforwardly
integrate Newton
equation of motion
we have seen in the
last class, you actually
conserve the total
energy of the system.
That is you conserve the
sum of the kinetic energy
plus the sum of the
potential energy.
And as you know from
statistical mechanics,
that is what is called the
microcanonical ensemble.
Sometimes it might be
more worthwhile to perform
your simulation at a
constant temperature.
And so that is what you would
call the canonical ensemble
in statistical mechanics.
And so you need to find a way
to impose a constant temperature
in your system.
Your system, in principle,
would conserve the energy.
And so it would have a
fluctuating temperature.
And again, from
statistical mechanics,
the larger your system is,
that is the closer you get
to the thermodynamically
limit, to the limit
of an infinitely large system.
It really doesn't matter because
an infinitely large system that
is simulated with, say, a
microcanonical algorithm
will also have 0 fluctuations
on the average temperature.
And so you would obtain the
same results in a microcanonical
or in a canonical simulation.
But as always, we deal with
finite systems maybe replicated
with periodic
boundary condition.
And so it might be more
convenient to choose
a canonical simulation,
so that we can fix
the temperature of our system.
Suppose that, again,
you want to study water.
You want to make sure
that you are studying
your system at a
temperature that is
consistent with liquid water.
Suppose that you
were studying water
with a microcanonical
simulation.
Again, what would you do is
choose your initial positions,
choose your initial velocities,
and let your system evolve.
But it's only after you
have let your system evolve
for a long time, that is after
your system has equilibrated,
that you can actually
measure, start averaging, some
of the macroscopic properties.
And so in the
microcanonical ensemble,
you could start, after
a while, to average
as a macroscopic
property the temperature.
The temperature is nothing else
than the average kinetic energy
of the ions.
Well, suppose that you
are studying water.
You have set up your
initial position,
your initial velocity.
You let this evolve.
And after a while, you discover
that the average temperature
is 150 kelvin.
And your system is frozen.
OK.
Well, what you have to do is
then restart your simulation.
It's not going anywhere if you
want to study liquid water.
And how could you change this?
Well, you could try using the
same initial configuration
that you had used before,
but much larger velocities,
hoping that once the system
evolves deterministically
from that initial point,
your average temperature
is going to be a temperature
in which your water is liquid.
But maybe you do it again, and
your velocity is too large.
And now, the temperature of
your system is 500 kelvin.
OK.
So you see the
problem, in this case,
in starting with a
microcanonical approach.
So it would be much
more convenient to have
an integration scheme
that actually allows
you to fix the temperature
instead of allowing
you to conserve the energy.
And there are several ways
in which something like this
can be done.
And again, you'll see examples.
But generally speaking,
we say that we
couple our dynamical
system with a thermostat.
That is nothing less than, if
you want, a computing device
that allows us to control,
in this case, the temperature
of our simulation.
And if instead of
the temperature
we wanted to control
the pressure,
we would couple our
system with a [INAUDIBLE]
and so on and so forth.
But if we focus for a moment
on the thermostat that's
the simplest, well, there
are sort of several ways
in which we can control the
temperature of our system.
And I've mentioned here sort
of three classes of devices
that we use to couple our
system with a thermostat.
And one approach could
be the Langevin dynamics
or the stochastic approach.
That is you try to sort of
simulate a constant temperature
by letting your system evolve
with the microcanonical
equation of motion.
But every now and
then, you give little
kicks to random atoms in which
those atoms either accelerate--
so they start picking
up more velocity.
And so the temperature
of your system rise.
And so you drive your system
to your required temperature.
Or instead of sort of kicking
and accelerating them,
you slow them down sort of
with a kick in the direction
opposite to its velocity.
And so you cool the system down.
And this is really sort of
analogous to the thermal bath
if you want.
You have all your
molecules moving around,
and collisions thermalize them.
So this would be a stochastic
or Langevin approach.
Another approach would be
a constrained approach.
Often, the simplest one
is the velocity rescaling.
Suppose that, again, you want
to keep a constant temperature.
Well, constant
temperature means that you
have fixed overall average
kinetic energy for your ions.
And so when integrating
the microcanonical equation
of motion, at
every time step you
have the velocity on every atom.
And if the average
kinetic energy
is below your target
temperature or above your target
temperature, the only
thing you need to do
is change your velocity in
order to have the constraint
that, at every time step, the
total kinetic energy of the ion
is fixed.
So if you want, a
constrained thermostat
involves keeping the total
kinetic energy of your system
fixed.
And in order to
do this, you need
to have actually an
integrating algorithm
that uses the
velocities to integrate
the equation of motions.
So something like the leap
frog Verlet that we want,
see, or the velocity Verlet that
we want, also see, would work.
But the simple Verlet that
I'll show you again in a moment
wouldn't actually be useful.
Because in the simple
Verlet, you never
control or never
use the velocity
of the system to integrate
the equation of motion.
So you are not able
actually to control
the velocity of your system.
And so you can't thermostat
your dynamical ensemble
using the simple Verlet.
And sort of the last
approach that is probably
the more generic and
the more powerful
is actually adding
to your sort of set
of equation of motion an
additional dynamical variable.
So up to now, the
dynamical variables
are all the position and all
the velocity of your particles
in the system.
Well, you could add an
additional dynamical variable
that I tend to sort of compare
it to some generic wind going
through the system.
And that sort of additional
dynamical variable
is something that either
slows down your particle
or accelerates your
particles in order
to fluctuate appropriately
around your target temperature.
And this is the
most elegant sort
of solution to the problem
of the thermalization,
and it's also the most powerful.
And we'll see examples
both in this class
and especially the
next class of applying
this extended approach.
And often, it goes under the
name of Nosé that was the first
one to develop the equation
of motion for a canonical
simulation at
constant temperature,
or actually Nosé-Hoover.
That was the other person that
made this equation a little bit
more tractable.
And again, a reminder
of the simple Verlet,
the only algorithm that we
have seen, that is sort of
summarized in here.
And what we are doing
is we are looking
at this trajectory,
this vector that
evolves as a function of time.
And we are just doing
a Taylor expansion.
That is, if we know
the position at time t,
the position at times t plus
delta t, the Taylor expansion,
involves the derivative of the
position with respect to time.
The second derivative
of the position
with respect to
time, that is nothing
than the acceleration,
the third derivative
and so on and so forth.
And I've only expanded
it up to the third order.
But the very nice thing
is that we can expand it
both forward in
time and backward
in time around the
instantaneous position.
And so using, you see, the
instantaneous velocity,
the instantaneous acceleration,
and the instantaneous third
derivative, we are able to
correlate the present position
with the next position in
time and the previous position
in time where delta t is this
fundamental discretization unit
that we call the time step.
And that is the
unit that we choose
to integrate our equation
of motion accurately enough.
And just by taking these two
expression and summing them,
we see that all the
terms cancel out.
And just by sort of moving left
and right the appropriate term,
we have just, by summing
these two Taylor expansion,
there's a fundamental
expression that
is really the core of the
simple Verlet algorithm.
And you see, this is the
recipe that we use, actually,
to integrate our equation
of motion in time.
That is what we are saying
is that the position at times
t plus delta t is related
to the position of time t
and the position at
times t minus delta t.
And so by knowing this position
and the previous position
and by knowing what
is the acceleration
at the present time--
and the acceleration
is nothing else
than the force
divided by the mass.
Here is where Newton's equation
of motion comes into play.
We are able to
predict what is going
to be the next position
with an accuracy that
is of the order of the fourth
power of your time step.
So if you want, if you are
going to have your time step,
the accuracy that you obtain
is going to be 16 times higher.
So one of the fundamental
sort of checks
that you want to do in your
molecular dynamic simulation
is that your time
step is small enough.
But obviously, it doesn't
need to be too small.
And again, we'll see an example
on how you can check for this.
And you see the simple
Verlet algorithm never uses
the velocity of your system.
It's able to calculate the
new position just using
the present acceleration
of the present force.
And so it's not
an algorithm that
allows you to control the
velocity of your particles.
So the velocity of
your particle is
something that is given to
you and you can, of course,
calculate.
Suppose that you
want to calculate
what is the kinetic
energy of your system.
Suppose that you
want to find out what
is the average temperature.
Well, you need to
calculate the velocity.
And again, you can use a simple
finite difference formula.
And you see, what we use is
actually the position of t
plus delta that's written
here and the position at t
minus delta that
is written here.
And these are
symmetric derivative.
And you could actually
do the homework
of inserting these
quantities and finding out
what is the order of error
in a power of delta t
for your velocity
and why we use,
actually, this
symmetric formula,
say, compared to a left
or a right derivative.
You could also calculate the
velocity as rt plus delta
t minus rt divided by delta t.
And it's easy to do it here.
If you want to calculate what
is the velocity at times t,
you obviously need to know
what is the derivative here.
This is the definition
of velocity.
And you can see that the
most accurate definition
of a derivative is obtained
by taking the value at rt
plus delta t and t minus delta t
and measuring this slope rather
than, say, measuring this
slope or measuring this slope.
So this slope here is given
by the symmetric derivative
that I have written
down here and is
the sort of most
accurate representation
of the true slope that is
the green position here.
And you can also do this not
only sort of graphically,
but analytically, just writing
out the explicit expressions.
I won't go into the details of
other integration algorithm.
But just to mention
another very common one
is what is called the Gear
predictor-corrector algorithm.
This is actually
not time invariant.
And it tends to be probably
more accurate than the Verlet
algorithm if you have
an analytical expression
for your forces, so
if you can actually
derive from a potential
field your force
and then obtain
your acceleration.
It tends to be much worse
than the Verlet algorithm
if you have noise in your data.
And that's actually
the case when
you perform an ab initio
molecular dynamic simulation
because the forces that
you obtain in an ab initio
simulation are exact only,
if at each time step,
you have reached the
perfect self-consistency.
And so ab initio
molecular dynamics
has some inherent
amount of noise
that calls for the use of a more
robust integration algorithm,
like this simple Verlet.
But if you are doing
classical molecular dynamics,
this is often superior.
And really it's sort of
an extension of the Verlet
algorithm.
That is, instead of
using just the first
and the second derivatives
of your trajectories,
it uses the third, the fourth,
and the fifth derivative,
and so on and so forth.
And then sort of it
estimates the error
and corrects, once you
have taken your time step,
for the difference
between your predicted,
say, acceleration
or third derivative
or fourth derivative that comes
from your Taylor expansion
and actually, say, the
acceleration that you
calculate.
That is the force
that you calculate
once you move in that position.
And again, using higher
order expressions--
that is using third and
fourth derivatives--
can give you more accuracy and
allow you to use longer time
step to integrate appropriately
your trajectory if you
have no noise in your forces.
But if you have
noise in your forces,
it can actually be more
catastrophic in the errors
that it obtains.
OK.
This was a reflection of some
of the things that we have seen.
One of the sort of
very simple concept
I wanted to sort
of remind you that
takes place whenever
we try to do
numerical integration of
a differential equation
is the concept of
Lyapunov instability.
That is sort of what you have
heard over and over again
called the butterfly
effect in weather forecast.
That is, if a butterfly beats
his wings in northern Africa,
we have a tornado
in the Caribbean.
And the reason
for that is saying
that, in any of this
differential equation, when you
try to integrate them,
an infinitesimal error
at the beginning
of your integration
will exponentially
increase to the point
that what comes at the
end of your simulation
can be radically different
for infinitesimal differences
in your initial condition.
That is to say
suppose that you have
an exact analytical trajectory.
That is you are
able to integrate
your equation of motion starting
from a certain initial position
and initial velocity here.
So in the limit of an
infinitesimal time step,
in principle you are going
to do a perfect integration
and recover this trajectory.
In practice, it means that,
for larger and larger steps,
what you will have
is that you'll
be able to sort of follow this
trajectory for a certain time.
But after a while,
you'll start diverging.
And the smaller
your time step is,
the more accurately
you are going
to reproduce this
trajectory for a while.
But at the end, the
exponential explosion
will always take place.
That is you start having
an exponentially increasing
difference between the exact
trajectory and the trajectory
that you are calculating.
Luckily, this doesn't
really matter.
This is very important.
And this is sort of true in
molecular dynamic simulation
of our small sample periodically
repeated in, which we want
to calculate thermal averages.
And it also applies to
the case of the butterfly
beating its wings and
creating a tornado.
What really happens is that all
these systems on the long time
scales are basically
inherently chaotic.
So all these
trajectories diverge
from the ideal trajectory,
but it doesn't really matter.
When we do a molecular
dynamic simulation,
we are not trying to reproduce
an exact trajectory starting
from the atomic timescales and
propagating for picoseconds,
nanoseconds, or microseconds.
Because what we want to find out
are either average properties
of the system--
well, it doesn't really matter
that the trajectory diverges.
Because even this
trajectory that diverge
still conserve the fundamental
macroscopic variables.
If you are doing a simulation
at constant temperature, what
it really matters is that
all these trajectories
correspond to evolutions
at constant temperature.
And then you are sampling
appropriately your phase space.
And even if you want to do
molecular dynamics of an event
instead of using it to
obtain an assemble average,
even if you want
to, say, find out
how an atom diffuses across
a barrier, what is really
your macroscopic
observable is the average
over tens, thousands,
millions of these events,
all sort of slightly
different from each other,
but all corresponding to
the overall constraint
of having the same
macroscopic observable.
So it doesn't really matter
that we replicate exactly
the trajectory,
neither for an ensemble
average of thermodynamical
quantities, nor for the case
in which we simulate
a specific event.
Because in any case,
what we need to do
is repeat the simulation
over and over again
to have appropriate statistics
and to have an average.
Of course, the only case where
having the exact trajectory
matters is that
if you are sending
a satellite in outer
space because you are not
sending 1 million satellites and
seeing what they do on average.
You want that satellite to
do something very precise.
And so you need to integrate
things very accurately.
And you need to keep
correcting your integration
as time goes by.
And we can actually
sort of formalize
this sort of concept of
Lyapunov instabilities
in terms, basically, of
an exponential divergence
in some metric of
our actual trajectory
from the ideal analytic
trajectory of our system.
OK.
So now, everything is in place.
We are doing our molecular
dynamic simulation.
First of all, how do
we check that something
is working, that what we
are doing makes sense?
Well, the first thing
is just making sure
that what you are doing
makes sense computationally.
It might still not
make sense physically,
but your sort of
order [INAUDIBLE]
is making sure that you are
integrating your equation
of motion appropriately.
Because, remember, you
need to choose a time step.
You need to choose a
discretization interval.
And the size of that
interval depends really
on what is the
typical atomic motion.
If you are studying a
system that is very cool
and is made of very
heavy atoms, you
can use very large times steps.
If your system is very hot and
made of very light atoms that
move much faster, you need
to use very small time steps.
But on average, there is really
a small range of time steps
that is really acceptable.
And they are of the order
of the femtoseconds, 10
to the minus 15 seconds.
So for something as light
as a hydrogen atom bound
to an oxygen, say,
in water molecule,
you might need to
use a time step as
small as 1/2 femtosecond.
For something in which
maybe you are studying,
say, liquid caesium,
a free electron metal
that is very heavy,
you might have
a time step that
can be appropriate
and as large as 20 femtoseconds.
But this is the
range, basically,
of the order of femtoseconds.
And the very important
thing is that you can always
check that your time
step is accurate enough.
Because if you are doing a
microcanonical simulation,
what you need to have is
that the total energy--
that is the sum of the potential
energy and the kinetic energy--
is conserved or, if you
want, that the kinetic energy
of the ions and the
potential energy of the ions
mirror each other exactly.
And again, in the limit of
infinitesimal time step,
this total energy line
should be perfectly flat.
As you increase your time
step, well, this line
will start to have some
microscopic oscillation.
So it will start fluctuate and,
depending on your algorithm,
could also have a
systematic drift.
A systematic drift,
generally speaking,
is very bad because it means
that your system is really
cooling down.
That is a systematic drift
means that your total energy is
going to get closer and closer
to the potential energy.
So the kinetic
energy of your ions
is decreasing and decreasing.
And so systematic drift
means that, after a while,
your system will
slow down to a halt.
And so you need
to check for that.
And then even if there
is no systematic drift,
a simple algorithm
like the Verlet
tend to be very good
at that, at not having
any systematic drift.
You need to make sure that your
fluctuation that will always
exist as long as you are
using a finite time step
are actually small enough.
So you want the fluctuation,
your total energy,
to be much, much smaller
than the fluctuation
in your potential energy,
say two orders of magnitude,
three orders of
magnitude smaller.
So that locally your system is
varying its potential energy,
but its total energy
is actually unchanged.
And again, thanks to the
power of the Verlet algorithm
that sort of scales as the
fourth power of your time step,
you can do very simple tests.
You half your time step, and
you should see your total energy
curve becomes much flatter.
And so you can basically
choose sort of what
is the optimal time step.
And you can even use a sort of
real space picture in which you
can look at the trajectory.
After all, what
you have are atoms
moving around and oscillating.
And so what you want to do in
a real trajectory of an atom
moving around is
you want to have
enough points to
describe correctly, say,
a period of an atom.
And the rule a thumb is that you
want between 20 to 100 points
in describing a full
period of an atom.
And that, again,
sort of brings us
back to the order of magnitude
of femtoseconds for the time
steps of your systems involved.
So once you have set up your
computational part correctly,
you still need to check out that
your simulation makes sense.
And in particular, the
sort of trickiest part
is making sure that you reach
thermodynamic equilibrium,
so that you lose memory of
your initial conditions.
And again, that's
actually something
in which the Lyapunov
instabilities, if you want,
help.
No matter how bad our choice
is, if we let the system evolve
long enough, our
trajectory will sort of
diverge from our
initial exact trajectory
that was somehow poorly chosen.
And it will become more
and more representative
of the thermodynamical ensemble
that we are simulating.
But it's still very
tricky to understand
if we are reaching equilibrium.
I've shown you here an example
in the case in which, say, we
are looking at a solid,
something like a slab of metal
in which we have a, say,
bulk atom in the metal.
And then as we move
towards the surface,
we have sort of second layer
atom and first layer atom.
And what we are
averaging here, what
is the sort of thermodynamical
observable we are interested,
is the mean square displacement.
That is how much
the atom fluctuates
around the initial condition.
And again, you'll see
more and more example
in what comes later of a
mean square displacement.
But you see, somehow
it's written here
in a reverse scale.
But if we start at time
t equal to 0 and we
measure what is the mean
square displacement,
well, at the beginning,
the atoms will keep moving.
If you think, this peak
here, this sort of 1/3 to 1/4
of a picosecond, is
a measure of what
is the period of
oscillation of an atom.
Because at the beginning,
the atom starts moving.
And from the point of
view of calculating
what is its average
displacement, it keeps moving.
At the very beginning of
the simulation, atoms move.
And then they start feeling the
potential from the other atom.
And they sort of settle in
an oscillatory movement.
And then you are
starting to average over
more and more oscillations.
And you see sort
of, in the bulk, you
fairly quickly converge.
These thin lines
are for the bulk.
You very quickly
converge to your sort
of final exact results.
But somewhere else
for the surface atoms,
it takes more time.
It takes a few seconds
before you finally
converge to your
sort of final result.
But again,
thermalization sort of
can be checked by looking at the
time evolution of the quantity
that you want to average.
Say, you could look at the
temperature of your system,
and you want to see
the quantity that you
are sort of monitoring
converge to a final result that
doesn't change as you increase
the length of your simulation.
And there are
quantities, again, that
are sort of easy to
converge and quantities that
are very difficult to converge.
Suppose for a moment that you
want to study actually, again,
the structure of liquid water.
Well, you could start from
a sample that is frozen--
that is ice-- and
all of a sudden
you increase the temperature
with your thermostat.
You bring it, say,
to 300 kelvin.
And then you let it evolve.
And you could sort
of look in time
as the sort of relative
position or the diffusion
coefficient of the water
molecule evolve in time.
And you would discover
that, depending
on the temperature, maybe you
need 10, 20, 30 picoseconds
to reach a situation after which
your expectation value do not
change if you increase your
simulation longer and longer.
This is sort of the
concept of equilibration.
If you were to do
the opposite, if you
wanted to find out what
is the structure of ice
by taking a sample of liquid
water and cooling it down,
your equilibration time
would be almost infinite.
Because if you take liquid
water and you cool it down,
it will actually not freeze
in the perfect crystalline
structure of ice.
But it will much more
likely sort of slow down
in a sort of glassy transition
in which it freezes.
It stop diffusing, but it's
only sort of locally coordinated
as ice should be.
But it's not in a
crystalline state.
What does that mean?
It means that what we
actually ended up with
is a situation that is not
at thermally representative
situation.
We are not in an equilibrium
state for a system,
but we have sort of and ended
up in a corner of phase space
out of which we are
never going to get out
unless we wait forever.
That is, even after
their water is
sort of frozen in
this glassy state,
if you keep simulating it
longer and longer and longer,
every now and then you'll have
a fluctuation that changes
the position of two water
molecules and two more water
molecules and two
water molecules.
And after a very long
time, you might actually
find that your system
has become crystalline.
But it's never going to
happen in the timescale
of your simulation.
So one needs to be
careful when one
does one of these simulation to
make sure that, actually, you
are sort of finding yourself
in a representative state.
And that's why some
of these issues,
like simulating
a solid to liquid
or a liquid to solid transition,
require particular care
and somehow require actually
knowing something of the system
that you want to discover.
And again, there is
an enormous debate
on what are some of the
phases of supercooled water.
That is, if you take
water, and it's very pure,
and you bring it down below the
regular freezing temperature,
well, you can keep
water liquid up to,
I think, 40 degrees
below the freezing point.
And you can do that
experimentally.
And you can do it
with simulation.
And then, all of a sudden, your
system will ultimately freeze.
And it will end up in phases
that neither the people doing
simulation, nor the
people doing experiment
can still agree with.
So there is sort of dark areas
in the phase diagram of water
at those low temperatures.
And people this discuss about
high density liquid and low
density liquid.
And a lot has been achieved
in the last 10 years.
But it's still not
formally known.
And this is why one really needs
to pay particular attention
to a number of these problems.
OK.
So suppose that
everything is going well.
You have initialized
properly your system.
You have sort of
weighted enough,
so that you have
actually lost memory
of your initial condition.
And if you want,
you should always
throw away the part of your
molecular dynamic trajectory
that corresponds to this
initial thermalization time
because it doesn't really
represent high quality data.
Only after you have
waited long enough,
say, in this
previous simulation,
only after you
have waited, say, 4
picosecond, you can start
taking averages of what is, say,
the mean square displacement
for a surface atom.
So you throw away
from your simulation
your thermalization
time, and you
start accumulating averages.
And again, the averages
that could be relevant,
if you are seeing a
microcanonical simulation,
you could look at the
average kinetic energy.
Because that average
kinetic energy
gives you the average
temperature of your system.
Or you could look at the
average pressure in your system.
Or I show you an
example in a moment.
You could look at
the potential energy
or what is sometimes
called the caloric curve.
So if you are actually
simulating a system
at different temperatures--
say, again, suppose
that you have water,
and you are still
in the frozen phase.
Well, the potential energy
will oscillate around
a certain value.
But remember, in order
to sort of melt water--
that is in order to go
at equilibrium from being
an infinitesimal
amount of temperature
below the melting temperature
and an infinitesimal amount
above the melting
temperature-- you
need really to give
to your system what
is called the latent heat.
In this case, the
latent heat of fusion
would be the heat
released when it cools
or the heat that you
give in order to melt it.
And so your average
potential energy
will have a discontinuity as
a function of temperature.
And we'll see it in an example.
And that's really a measure
from your molecular dynamic
simulation of this fundamental
thermodynamical quantity.
Or you could look, say, in
liquid water at the diffusion
coefficient, so the means
square displacements.
And we'll see this.
Or you could look
at the structure,
the geometric structure,
of your liquid.
And again, sort of molecular
dynamics techniques
were actually initially
developed for system
like liquids in which
it was much more
difficult to have analytical
expression for something
like the structure.
I mean, if you are
studying a crystal,
the structure is
somehow trivial.
And you can obtain it
from X-ray experiments,
but you can also obtain it
from total energy calculation,
minimizing the energy with
respect to your volume.
If you are studying
a liquid, again, you
can have information on your
sort of local structure.
That is how far the
molecules keep on average
from each other in the
simulation from diffraction
experiments.
But you don't have an
immediate computational way
to calculate data
like you have done it
for a solid in which you
were, again, minimizing energy
with respect to volume.
What we really need is to do a
molecular dynamic simulation.
And this is sort of the
first of the examples
I want to show you
today of application
of molecular dynamics.
That is one in which we
calculate ensemble average.
And in particular, we,
say, calculator, say,
the structure of liquid water.
I'll also give you an
example, a couple of examples,
of a chemical
reaction that is using
molecular dynamics to
look at the evolution
in real time of a system.
And I'll sort of hint at
this more general idea
that we can use these
thermodynamical analogies
and sort of molecular
dynamic analogies
to actually solve complex
optimization problems.
OK.
And so this is an example from
a molecular dynamic simulation,
actually an ab initio
molecular dynamic simulation,
and one in which one
tries to figure out
what is the local
structure of the liquid.
And so how do you actually
define structure in a liquid?
Well, sort of one of the
fundamental quantities
is what is called the
pair correlation function.
Suppose that we are
looking, again, at water.
We have the water molecules.
So say we have an oxygen
atom on each molecule.
And so what we can
sort of ask ourselves
is, what is the probability
of finding another oxygen
atom at a certain
distance from one oxygen?
So you could sort
of imagine yourself
sitting on a water molecule
sitting on that oxygen
and sort of
monitoring on average
what is the distribution of
all the other oxygen atoms.
And this would be one of these
pair correlation function.
This is specifically
for the case of water.
I'll tell you in a moment
what the difference
between these curves is,
but what we are plotting
is the probability
of finding an oxygen
atom at a certain
distance if I'm
sort of sitting on one
of these water molecules
and running around.
And as you can see, the
probability below roughly 2.3,
2.4 angstrom is 0.
So you never find an oxygen atom
closer than 2.3, 2.4 angstrom.
And this is because,
obviously, you
know, molecules
by Pauli repulsion
and electrostatic repulsion,
sort of repel each other very
strongly at close distance.
This, in the
Lennard-Jones potential,
was the 1 over r
to the 12th term.
When you get very
close, the repulsion,
it's so strong that you never
get very, very, very close.
Actually, the only time you
sort overcome this short range
repulsion is in something
like nuclear fusion
in which you can manage to
get, say, hydrogen atom to get
so close together that
actually their nuclei melt
into a helium.
But you see, at this standard
condition of pressure
and temperature,
really the probability
of finding some oxygen atom
up to 2.3 angstrom is 0.
And then all of a
sudden, the probability
of finding an oxygen
atom skyrockets.
What does this mean?
Well, it means that,
actually, to have,
if you add an oxygen
atom in a water molecule,
it's very likely to have other
water molecules surrounding you
at a distance that is a
tad shy of 3 angstrom.
OK.
This is what the chemists would
call the first solvation shell.
OK.
The water molecule sort of
runs around in the liquid.
And there's a certain
number of water molecules
that are at a certain
average distance that
is around 2.6, 2.8 angstrom.
And so this is a
solvation shell,
a shell of water molecules
that, on average, surround
this molecule.
And because there is a sort
of average shell of water
molecules around, once you
move outwards from this oxygen,
then there is going to be a
depletion of water molecules.
Because there is one shell
at a certain distance.
You move further,
it becomes much more
difficult to have
water molecules
at an intermediate distance.
And this is really sort
of a general description
for all kinds of liquids.
And then you sort of
move farther away.
And then there is a
second solvation shell.
OK, there is structure
in the liquid.
You have a water molecule.
On average, it's surrounded
by a first shell.
And then, on average, that's
surrounded by a second shell.
And as you move
farther and farther,
the boundaries become
farther and farther.
So you can sort of spot
a third solvation shell.
But once you move
farther and farther away,
if you look at what is the
probability distribution 10
angstrom, 100 angstrom, 1
meter away, it becomes flat.
That is, if you look what is the
probability of finding a water
molecule 1 meter away or 1
meter plus 1/10 of an angstrom,
there is really no difference.
Because you have lost
long range order.
You have lost structure.
This would be very different,
say, in a perfect crystal.
So if you study something like
silicon at 0 temperature--
and for a moment, forget about
zero-point motion and quantum
effects.
Think just at a silicon
crystal as being
made of classical
particles at 0 temperature.
They are perfectly periodic.
And so what you would
find, you could still
define pair
distribution function.
And what you would
find is Dirac's delta.
That is the probability
of finding a silicon
atom at a certain distance
from new silicon atoms,
say, sitting on
the origin is going
to be 0 until you hit the
distance of your first shell
of neighbors.
And then it's sort of infinite
or properly normalized
at Dirac's delta.
And then it's 0 again, and
then another Dirac's delta,
and 0 again, and then
another Dirac's delta.
And as you move farther
and farther away,
the density of
your Dirac's delta
becomes higher and higher.
Because, again, if you are
at 1 meter of distance,
there are an enormous
amount of possibilities
of finding sort of a
combination of lattice vectors
that give you a silicon
atom in that position.
And so if we were to smooth
out those Dirac's delta, that
is if we were to have
some temperature,
we would start seeing something
a little bit like this.
The first Dirac's delta
would become slightly larger.
The second Dirac's delta,
the third Dirac's delta,
we move farther
and farther away.
There are so many
close to each other
that they all start overlapping.
And also, for a crystal
at final temperature,
you would start to have
this pair correlation
function that goes towards 1.
In a liquid, it's a
much more dramatic.
And this quantity tells you
also something fundamental
about the appropriate size
of your simulation cell.
Remember that you are studying
something in periodic boundary
condition.
So the question is, if we
want to study liquid water,
how large should
our unit cell be?
I mean, does it
need to contain 10
to the 23, the
Avogadro's number,
of water molecules in
a macroscopic sample?
No.
And this is a
fundamental concept.
It needs to be large enough
so that the correlation
between your molecule
in the origin
and that molecule
periodically repeated is 0.
That is, by the time this pair
correlation function reaches 1,
it means that you have
lost any structure.
So somehow you
don't have any way
of recognizing that there
is a molecule in the origin
or that molecule is 0.1
angstrom displaced away.
So a molecule that is on
the origin and a molecule--
suppose that you
continue this curve
and maybe becomes
15 angstroms away.
Well, those two
molecules are not
aware of each other's existence.
And so if you are
studying your system,
such data, the distance
between a molecule
and your periodic
image is 15 angstrom.
Actually, from
all point of view,
you are studying a
system that behave
as it was an infinite system.
Your molecule sitting on
the origin moves around.
And it sees independently
all the molecules with which
on average it interacts.
And the molecule that
is 15 angstroms away
is so far away that
there is no correlation.
And so for all
practical purposes,
this molecule on the origin
sees an infinity liquid system.
It doesn't recognize
that there is a boundary
and things are
periodically repeated.
And this is absolutely
very important.
And that's why we can actually
simulate a realistic liquid
with actually very
few molecules.
It turns out that, for
something like water,
you need only 32 water molecules
at sort of regular conditions
in the liquid, 300
kelvin, 350 kelvin,
to actually simulate
an infinite system.
You don't need to put
more water molecules.
It won't change anything.
Of course, as you sort
of get closer and closer
to a phase transition, remember
that, at the exact temperature
of the phase transition,
the solid and the liquid
are in equilibrium.
So the free energy of the
solid and the free energy
of the liquid are identical.
So it doesn't cost anything
in terms of free energy
to transform the solid in
the liquid and the liquid
in the solid.
And that means that you can have
fluctuation, bubbles of solid
and bubble of liquid,
that have arbitrary sizes.
So at the exact temperature
of the phase transition,
you have a divergence in
this characteristic length.
That is you can have
fluctuations of all sizes.
So if you were to study
the system, exactly
the phase transition, you
need an infinite sized system.
But as you move away from
the phase transition,
very quickly the correlation
function dropped down.
And it's something like 25
kelvin above the melting point.
It's so short that you
need only 32 molecules.
And water is actually
an excellent example
to sort of show you also what
goes wrong in the simulation.
OK.
Because what I've
plotted here are actually
a result of accurate
or very accurate
ab initio molecular
dynamics simulation.
And we know that sort of
density functional theory
actually describes
very well the hydrogen
bonds, so describes the
interaction between water
molecules very well.
But you can see it here.
You see, these are the
pair correlation function.
You see this sort of
set of curves here,
the more structural set of
curves, taken at 325, 350, 375
kelvin.
There is actually very, very
little difference between them.
And that's a bad sign.
So what we are seeing is
that this sort of structure
is not changing as we
increase the temperature.
And then we increase
the temperature, say,
from 375 to 400 kelvin.
And you see this
different set of curves.
You see the red and the green.
So there is really a
discontinuous change
in going from 375 to 400 kelvin.
What has happened
in our simulation?
Well, it turns out that, at 400
kelvin, our water is liquid.
At 375, it's a glassy system.
So it's an amorphous glass.
And you see it doesn't
change with temperature.
And you need to get to 400
kelvin for it to become liquid.
What is the bad thing here?
It's not that the water is
in an amorphous glass state.
It's reasonable, as I said, even
if it's not the result that we
want, to find an amorphous
states for a lot of liquids
that have been cooled down
below the melting temperature
especially sort of liquids
that tend to have sort
of pseudo-covalent bonding.
You study carbon
below its melting pot.
You study silicon.
You study something like water.
They tend to want to be sort
of tetrahedrally coordinated.
And they tend to sort of form
a lot of glassy structure.
What is really bad is
that the melting of water
doesn't seem to be taking
place at 273 kelvin,
but it takes place
at 400 kelvin.
OK.
So if you want, if you were to
use densely functional theory
and sort of molecular dynamics
to predict what happens,
we would all be frozen to death.
You need to be at 400 kelvin
to see something liquid.
And you see, then
you can also compare.
This is very good.
There are a lot of
experiments that
look at what is the
structure of water.
You can do this with
neutron scattering.
X-ray scattering.
So you can probe
the local structure.
And you see this is
what the experiment is.
So it's sort of good, but
it's really not perfect.
And so what's going on here?
What's wrong in this?
Well, in many ways,
we actually think
that density functional
theory is good enough
to simulate water.
OK.
So the energy for any
given configuration
is given accurately
by quantum mechanics.
But there is something
very important
that I sort of hinted in
some of the discussion.
300 kelvin, 400 kelvin
is a temperature
at which molecules can still
display quantum effects
in their vibrational
degrees of freedom.
That is when we discussed
at certain point
the fact that a simple
molecule like hydrogen
is actually only discrete
vibrational energy
and discrete vibrational states.
And at 0 temperature,
it's in the state
called zero-point motion.
That is a purely quantum
mechanical effect
and doesn't really come
from describing correctly
the energy of the electrons
in the potential of the ions,
but comes from the fact
that the ions themselves
are quantum particles.
And the excitation
of a quantum particle
from one state to
another vibrational state
is in itself quantized.
And so what turns out
to happen in water
is that the hydrogen oxygen
stretching frequency.
OK.
So the frequencies by
which one hydrogen beats
against another oxygen
are actually very high,
are of the order of 3,000
centimeters to the minus 1.
So that's a typical
sort of measure
of vibrational frequency.
They are, in particular,
sort of 10 times larger
than the average
kinetic temperature
at room temperature.
So that means that, in reality,
those vibrational modes cannot
be excited.
They are frozen in
their ground state.
So in all this liquid, you have
a variety of vibrational modes,
some that are very
soft and that involve
sort of how one water molecule
correlates with other water
molecules.
But you have some very
stiff intermolecular
vibrational degrees of
freedom that you can't excite.
And so the classical
description of the ions is good,
but it's not perfect.
And that's what brings
us this error here.
If we were to study-- sadly,
there are no experiments, say,
at 3,000 kelvin.
But if you were to do an
experiment of, obviously,
water at a sort of
fixed volume, so
at very high pressure
at 3,000 kelvin, then
the ions would all sort of
behave as classical particles
and probably our agreements
would be much better.
But at this low
temperature, some
of these vibrational degrees
of freedom are actually frozen.
And they can't
exchange temperature.
They can't exchange
vibrational energy
with the rest of the
degrees of freedom.
It's the same concept by which
the specific heat of solids
follows the Dulong
and Petit law.
And it's much smaller than
its ideal sort of value
at low temperatures.
Because even in a solid,
where vibrational frequencies
tend to be much lower than 3,000
centimeters to the minus 1,
it tends to be of the order 300,
400 centimeters to the minus 1.
So they tend to be all
populated at room temperature.
But in the regime
of low temperatures,
much lower 300 kelvin, some
of those degrees of freedom
are also frozen out.
So they can't
exchange temperature
when you increase the heat.
And so the specific
heat of the system
is much smaller because a lot
of those degrees of freedom
can't actually talk
with your heat bath.
OK.
So this was an example.
Let's see another
example in which
we look at ensemble averages.
And this is the example
of the caloric curve.
So that is plotting
the potential energy
as a function of time.
This is done for a sort of
classical molecular dynamic
simulation.
So you see it's using
6,400 particles, so
a very large amount.
This is actually a slab of
lead in the 1, 0, 0 direction.
And you see, if we simulate
this at 600 kelvin,
well, this is as a
function of time.
This is a very long
simulation, you see.
We are talking about
the nanoseconds.
OK.
So it's of the order
of 1 million time steps
if we were using times
step for a femtosecond.
And you see, this
is how the sort
of average potential energy
fluctuates at 607 kelvin.
And then we increase
the temperature,
and you see it fluctuates
around another value.
Increase the temperature,
it fluctuates another value.
We increase the temperature a
little bit more from 625 kelvin
to 630 kelvin, and what
happens in this solid?
You see, at the beginning,
during, if you want,
your thermalization
time, you oscillate
around a certain value.
But then something
happens, and your system
goes into a new state in which
the average potential energy
oscillates around a new value.
What your system
has done, it's gone
through a melting transition.
And so the difference
between, if you want,
the potential energy just
below the melting temperature
and the potential energy just
above the melting temperature
is this latent heat of
fusion, the energy that
is needed to melt the crystal
or the energy that is released
when the crystal solidifies.
And this is actually a sort
of very specific system
in which there is a sort of
more exotic phase transition.
And that's why molecular
dynamics simulations
were needed.
It was a system
in which there was
what is called incomplete
surface melting.
That is, if you look at
the surface of lead 1,
0, 0, it starts melting
at a temperature that
is lower than the temperature
at which the bulk melts.
And this is because
surface atoms are really
different from bulk atoms.
So they have their
own phase transition.
And it's temperature for
that phase transition
that is different from the
bulk melting temperature.
So you heat up lead.
All of a sudden, you see that
the surface becomes liquid.
And then you need to reach
another critical temperature
before also the bulk melts.
OK.
So a couple of examples we have
seen from ensemble averages.
As I said, we can also
use molecular dynamics
to actually follow
a chemical reaction.
And so this is another
example from ab
initio molecular
dynamic simulation.
Because what we really
want to investigate
is how we can take a molecule
of methane-- you see C and H4.
There are four hydrogen atom.
One is sort of the pink and
below, beneath the yellow.
We want to figure out
how to break this apart.
This is a fundamental
technological problem
because we have enormous
reserves of methane is
what people call natural gas.
But it's extremely expensive
to transport because you really
need to liquefy it and carry
it in sort of cryogenically
frozen containers.
So it's much more expensive
to transport methane
than to transport oil.
And that's why we are
actually not using
sort of all the methane natural
gas reserves that exist.
So one of the important
things that we could do
is actually transform methane
in some higher and heavier
hydrocarbons, like
methanol, that we
can transport much more easily.
And that, in principle,
is very doable.
Methane has an enormous
amount of energies
ready to be released.
But sadly, in order to
release the energy, in order
if you want to burn methane
or in order to break it apart,
you need first to break apart
the first carbon-hydrogen bond.
And that's tough.
Once you break
that hydrogen bond,
all the other hydrogen go
and release a lot of energy.
But breaking this
is very difficult.
And we want to do this in
a very controlled manner
in order not to burn methane,
but construct some higher
hydrocarbon, like methanol.
And so one sort of very
suggestive hypotheses
is actually using
nanostructured catalyst, that
is using well-known
catalyst transition metals,
like platinum in this
case, but catalysts
that have a very exotic
surface, so that they
become more reactive.
They can help break part of
this carbon-hydrogen bond.
And so this is where ab
initio molecular dynamics come
into play because we
can study the system
and try to figure out what
happens when we take a methane
molecule, and we throw
it to a platinum surface.
And as you can see,
nothing happens.
And we are very, very
happy, not so much
because we have sort of
simulated an interesting
system, but because actually we
can measure the kinetic energy
of the molecules coming down.
And we can measure
when it comes out.
And we find out that it
has the same velocity,
but opposite direction.
So our system is conserving
energy very accurately.
But you know, what
you can do now
with your molecular
dynamic simulation
is try to figure out if
this is the whole story.
That is, well, as you
see, we have sort of
thrown this molecule
into the trough here.
Because we thought
that maybe this area
is the most
catalytically active.
It's where there are more
platinum atoms able to sort
of rip this thing apart.
Well, it turns out
that, actually,
the most catalytically
active part of the surface
is the under-coordinated
platinum atoms sitting here
on the ridge.
And you see, when the
molecule falls down on this,
it very easily
breaks apart this.
And so doing our
ab initio MD, we
discover that these
under-coordinated atoms
are actually much more
active than the sort
of surface-like atoms down here.
So under-coordinating
a transition metal
is actually very helpful.
And this is actually
what bacteria that
eat methane for a living do.
So what those bacterias
do, they have an enzyme
that is called a methane
monooxygense that
actually is able to break apart
this carbon-hydrogen bond.
And what it has, it
has sort of two iron
atoms in the middle of a sort
of porphyrin like structure.
And those under-coordinated
transition metals
do all the trick.
Other examples in which a
molecular dynamic simulation
helps us understanding
the structure
of microscopic system--
as shown here.
In this case, what we
are doing is taking
a liquid droplet of aluminum.
So this is aluminum above
its melting temperature.
That is sort of 933 kelvin.
It's been thermalized,
and so it's a liquid.
And then we have a
surface that could
be, say, two different
crystallographic orientation,
the 1, 1, 0 surface and
the 1, 1, 1 surface.
And what we do is we drop this
liquid droplet on the surface.
And we sort of see what is
the evolution of the system.
And on the 1, 1, 0 surface, that
is one of these metal surfaces
that undergo a pre-melting
transition where the surface
itself--
you can see it here--
becomes liquid-like.
What happens is that you
have a liquid droplet falling
on a sort of liquid surface.
And so it wets completely the
surface, and this moves around.
You throw this same liquid
droplet on aluminum 1, 1, 1,
that is a surface
that doesn't matter
and that actually overheat.
You can sort of bring a
crystalite of aluminum,
and you can look at
the 1, 1, 1 surface.
And you can bring it above
the melting temperature,
and it will not
melt until you reach
sort of a critical
temperature of 1,000 kelvin.
Well, this liquid droplet
actually doesn't wet away,
but it forms, you
see, a little disk.
And you can actually
sort of measure
what is this contact angle.
And so you can figure out
what is the surface tension.
And you can understand
a lot basically
about the free energy of the
liquid and the solid just
by those contact angles.
Another example for which
I have another movie
is sort of related
to what you have seen
in the sort of previous slide.
And it's sort of
looking at actually
what do adatom on aluminum
1, 0, 0 surface do.
And so you see what we do is,
in ab initio molecular dynamics,
we put an atom here.
And we let the system evolve
at a certain temperature.
In this case, it's
evolving at 500 kelvin.
That is roughly 1/2 of
the melting temperature.
And again, you can
see some features
of an ab initio molecular
dynamic calculation in which we
can simulate very few atoms.
And so actually,
in this simulation,
you see our surface area is
given just by 16 atoms, this 4
by 4 here.
And then we have periodic
boundary condition.
So this atom and this atom are
doing exactly the same thing,
but we are actually
ourselves in the condition
in which there is no correlation
between what this atom does
and what this atom does.
So these atoms sort of
behave independently
from what this atom does.
Just because, at
this temperature,
the correlation length between
these two is very, very short.
And what I'm not showing
here in this simulation
is actually the lower
layers of out aluminum slab
just because they are not
doing anything interesting.
And so we want to understand
how the atoms move around.
And everyone would
have sort of guessed
that adatoms on the
surface hop around,
sort of the classical
model of diffusion,
from one side here in the
middle to another side
here in the middle.
But you see, you
do your ab initio
molecular dynamic
simulation, and you
discover that something
very intriguing happens.
Actually, adatoms do
not diffuse by hopping,
but they diffuse
by sort of diving
into the surface layer and sort
of pushing another atom out.
And you'll see it again
in a cleaner fashion.
You see the diffusion takes
place by an atom diving in.
Look at this.
This sort of, in a
moment, will dive in
and pushes this sort
of second atom out.
And by the time it
reaches here, now you
see it appearing in
periodic boundary condition.
And again, the molecular
dynamic simulation
has given you an insight on
the microscopic process that
provided density functional
theory is accurate.
And it, for this
particular system,
is actually very different from
any kind of physical intuition
would have told you.
And it's 1 more minute.
Let me finish this movie because
something more interesting
takes place once you increase
the temperature to 700 kelvin.
This is what we have done
in the simulation here.
And what you actually see
is that the first surface
layer starts really
behaving as a liquid.
OK.
So we actually have
a phase transition
that is induced by the
presence of that atom in which
this first layer, if you
monitor long enough what
the mean square
displacements are,
how the atoms are, well,
the atoms in this layer
move around like a liquid.
But they don't move
around below the surface.
And the surface
remain crystalline.
And I'll finish the movie.
We actually then, in our
computational experiment,
all of a sudden we can remove
atoms from our liquid sample.
That is we can sort
of take them away.
And we actually see very quickly
that the system crystallizes
again.
And you'll see it in a moment.
See, we have removed atoms.
We have actually
removed two atoms.
So we have created a vacancy.
And the system has
become crystalline.
Now, the atoms vibrate again
around the crystalline surface.
And there is a vacancy here.
And from this, we also
discover how the vacancy moves.
And you'll see that there is an
atom from below that hops out.
You see this hops out,
leaving a hole here.
And an atom from the
first layer pops down.
So the vacancy that was
here has moved here.
And again, the way
it has moved is not
sort of the usual way in
which one could imagine
a vacancy moving by a
surface atom moving around,
but it actually involves a
second layer atom jumping out.
OK.
With this movie,
I'll finish today's
molecular dynamic simulation.
We'll sort conclude the
MD part on Thursday.
And as a reminder,
today was also
the deadline for your
second assignment, lab two.
And you can give it to
me or to one of the TAs.
And otherwise, we'll
meet on Thursday.